the Joe Rogan experience if you face in
the opposition to this is there anybody
that thinks is a fruitless idea I know
there were people that were actually I
was very shocked
I read people that were actually happy
that your project didn't work the first
time what the [ __ ] man there's people
that I think it's a thing like cause
you're this really hopeful young
intelligent guy who comes up with the
solution I think it probably was II
think he's so [ __ ] smart front cam I
hope it fails and when it failed people
actually enjoyed it yeah yeah does that
hurt no so for me so yes of course
since the really since the beginning
2013 there have been people
yeah like relatively small group of
people would there have been people that
have been opposing it and most of them
ironically enough are people that care
about the ocean because they don't feel
it's the right way to to to tackle the
issue and but the way I deal with it is
you at least what I used to do in the
beginning now they're virtually there
aren't many new arguments anymore but
just better get right them out every
single argument rationally analyze them
no emotions emotions only muddle your
your thinking in that way and make a
distinction okay is this something where
this person has a point if so great
because you know whether have somebody
else pointing it out to me then us
having to learn it in the field and you
know having a having unnecessary failure
and if the person doesn't have a point
if it's just you know assumption or
unfounded or whatever you know then is
very easy for me to just ignore it and
so and then the question is well what
motivates people to be negative and I
think there's pretty four reasons first
of all it's it's no genuine skepticism
whether it can be done and I think
that's how that's healthy and I think
we've proved most of those arguments
wrong now but of course there's still
you know the whole scale up thing which
it's to have to do so so bit of that but
it's kind of morphing now to a few other
things like one thing is human
risk perception which sometimes I think
is a it's a cause of some opposition
where it's very easy for people to
ignore the the baseline when they look
at risks so you know you can for example
say okay nuclear power super risky we
shouldn't do that but then if you
compare to the baseline of other sources
of energy it's actually probably the
least risky source of energy there is
even solar energy is causes more deaths
per megawatt hour then and then nuclear
power because people fall off roofs so
so it's really so if you ignore the
baseline and if you say okay
doing this cleanup we shouldn't do it
because there's all these potential
risks right of you know potentially
there is some see lives that may be
caught potentially there are these moral
hazards there's all these risks and you
know basically best thing to do is not
do it what people then are ignoring is
sort of the certain hazard of these
hundreds of millions of kilos of plastic
that's already in the ocean and if you
were to pose the opposite question to
say okay so if we were to go to the
ocean right now and just dump the
equivalent amount of plastic that we
were to take out would dump it into the
ocean would you would you think that's a
good plan and then well probably the
answer is is no so so I think there's
there's a bit of this you know of course
of course what we're doing it's new
there are risks involved but as long as
we map them well we take things step by
step I think they're manageable and
they're definitely not risks or reasons
to to not do it because of course the
baseline is that there is already doing
a lot of harm being done by the status
quo so I think that's one argument
behind people's opposition there's also
a bit of zero what it calls there are
some game bias where people are saying
well we shouldn't do
this because the resources would be
better spent elsewhere I saw an op-ed in
Wired a few weeks ago where people were
saying well or just one person actually
it was was writing where this person
said you shouldn't worry about the
plastic pollution issue you shouldn't do
anything about it because climate change
is the biggest issue and our attention
should go there plastic pollution is
just a distraction and that's foolish
well yeah I think yeah there's seven
half billion people's in the world and
we can do more than one thing at the
same time I think yeah I mean which
should you not wash your dishes because
your carpet is dirty I mean it doesn't
make any sense both of them are a
problem I don't clean both of them this
is this idea that you should only think
about climate change so oh don't think
about the giant Pacific Garbage Patch is
twice as big as Texas today
are you [ __ ] serious it's a dumb
argument both of them are important to
think about both of them important but a
part of writing an article today is
writing something that people will get
upset about that's part of it is like
generating our clickbait stuff having
controversial opinions being contrarian
all those things are profitable today
there's a giant part of why people write
articles they don't write articles they
don't write articles to state an
objective well-thought-out perspective
always sometimes people do but a lot of
times people make some clique baby
[ __ ] and they kind of twist a story
and twist an idea who you are
twist it to sort of make their narrative
make more compelling be more compelling
and bright sell more or click more and
get more ad sales yeah I wonder whether
that's in part behind the growing
tribalism and polarization that you see
everywhere social media I mean the fact
that Facebook's algorithms in in a sense
support outrage right like these these
things are designed to support my friend
Ari Shaffir attest to this and it's
really interesting because he tested it
to find out what did it what does it
actually support what it actually
supports is what you're interested in if
you're interested me outraged it'll show
you the things that outraged you so he
decided to just only YouTube puppies
yeah and that's all YouTube it's shown
there's puppies he's like no you
[ __ ] this is what you're into if
you're into [ __ ] and getting bad a
out the border and getting mad about the
climate and getting mad about abortion
and getting mad about whatever the [ __ ]
it is that's what it'll show you because
that's what you're interested in you
know my YouTube feed is mostly muscle
cars and fights why cuz that's what I'm
interested in yeah you know I'm just
that's like you know and occasionally
science things yeah but that's just
because that's what you search for
that's it'll show you what you search
for I'm sure you're somewhat happy that
it shows you those things yes sure I
don't think I don't think it's as
sinister as people want to say it is I
think that the issue is human nature we
are compelled to get upset about things
and I think a lot of it is people that
feel disempowered in their own existence
the people that you were talking about
that are stuck in cubicles and that are
staring at that clock waiting for the
buzzer to ring so they can go home those
people are online they're tweeting
they're taking a [ __ ] and tweeting [ __ ]
this guy's a little kid think she's
gonna fix this [ __ ] trip there's a
lot of what's going on there's a lot of
people that are upset because they're
just it's fun to be upset when your life
sucks it's fun to [ __ ] on somebody it's
fun to get mad about the border or when
you know you don't live it in [ __ ] it
sounds Dakota you're nowhere near the
border what are you worried about what
you're worried about you're just angry
people just angry you know it's like
these aren't logical discussions that
people are having their shout offs and
and it's it's a natural part of human
nature to get upset about stuff and you
know and even someone who's doing
something as beautiful as your
perspective and or your your idea
instead of just saying oh this this guy
is doing something amazing we need
someone like this who's just as
innovative and just as inspired to try
to tackle this climate issue you need
more people I can this is amazing
instead of that like you're spending
your resources incorrectly yeah yeah
yeah well yeah yeah are you talking
about it yeah and yeah I suppose it's
you know from the perspective of the
person who who writes that it's he
thinks he's got a point
yeah and and that and and indeed if
you're just saying what everyone else
says nobody would see your opinion
exactly that's a big part
[Applause]